[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
توعدت حركه طالبان بالرد على مقتل سته عشر
مدنيا افغانيا الاحد برصاص الجندي
الامريكي اطلق النار عمدا على مجموعه من
الاطفال والنساء والشيوخ في قريه في ولايه
قندهار
من جهته قال البرلمان الافغاني ان صبره
نفذ بشان ما وصفها بالطريقه البربريه التي
تتصرف بها القوات الاجنبيه في البلاد
ام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسيين مع احبابك والاعتداءات الجنود
الامريكيين في افغانستان مؤخرا فكيف
ستنعكس على طريقه تعامل الافغان معهم وما
اثر هذه الاعتداءات على صوره حكومه كرزاي
داخليا وما انعكاساتها على مستقبل العلاقه
بين واشنطن وكابول
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ما ان هدات نظام الغضب التي اشعلها حلق
جنود امريكيين نسخا من القران الكريم في
افغانستان حتى اقدم جندي امريكي اخر او
ربما مجموعه جنود بحسب روايه احد شهود
العيان على قتل سته عشر مدنيا افغانيا
اغلبيتهم العظمى من الاطفال والنساء
والشيوخ لم تترك الطريقه التي ارتكبت بها
الحادثه فرصه لتبرير او اعتذار من قبيل
ادعاء الدفاع عن النفس او الشعور بالتهديد
فقد خرج منفذ او منفذو المجزره من قاعدتهم
عندا ثم تعقب ضحاياهم من منزل الى منزل في
حادثه هي الاكثر من بين سلسله اعتداءات
سجلت على جنود امريكيين في الفتره الاخيره
مثقل الخطوات جاء يقدم اعتذارا اخر للشعب
الافغاني متحدث باسم القوات الامريكيه
قادته الى هذه المنصه مجزره اقترفها زميل
له قتل فيها بدم بارد جمعا من القرويين
العزل في قندهار سته عشر مدنيا بينهم تسعه
اطفال وثلاثه لم يجد الجندي الامريكي
غيرهم ليس ب فيهم برصاصه في حادثه
اعتبرتها واشنطن تصرفا فرديا لا علاقه لها
باخلاقيات جيشها انا لمثل هذا التبرير ان
يدفع غضب الافغانيين وهم الذين وسعت
المجزره بينهم دائره ال مقتنعين بان الوقت
حان لرحيل القوات الاجنبيه عامه والقوات
الامريكيه على وجه الخصوص قناعه صنعها
سياق من الحوادث المختلفه في حيثياتها
المماثله في تاثيراتها قبل ثلاثه اسابيع
اقدم جنود امريكيون على احراق المصحف
الشريف فكانت النتيجه احتجاجات واسعه لم
تنتهي الا بسقوط ثلاثين افغانيا من
المتظاهرين
قبلها نقلت الشبكات الاجتماعيه مشاهد جنود
الامريكيين يتبولون على جثث القتلى طالبان
في تحد لابسط المعايير الاخلاقيه التي
يباهي الجيش الامريكي
بانه يلتزم بها هدف امام الرئيس الافغاني
حامد كرزاي مبديا اسفه للحادثه الداميه في
محاوله على ما يبدو لتطويق تداعياتها
المحتمله على العلاقات الثنائيه خاصه ما
تعلق منها باوجه التنسيق الجاريه
والمرتقبه بين الجانبين
كانت الولايات المتحده تامل في توقيع
قريبا اتفاقيه استراتيجيه مع شركائها
الافغان تشرع لمستشاري الجيش الامريكي
العسكريين البقاء طويلا اثر انسحاب وحداته
القتاليه بحلول الفين واربعه عشر اثر
سنوات من القتال الشرس مع طالبان الحركه
المسلحه التي اعتبرت ما بات يعرف ب مجزره
قندهار دليلا على الشرعيه ووجاهه مقاومتها
للوجود الاجنبي في بلادها حرب اختبرت
انجيلا ميركل شيئا من او حالها في اخر
زياره لها الى افغانستان وبتعرف المستشاره
الالمانيه كيف استدرجت جنود التحالف
الدولي فاردت كثيرا منهم لكنها في المقابل
تجهل نهايتها التي تعد في نظر كثيرين اكثر
كلما تجدد ما يشبه حادثه قندهار
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من كابل فضل
الهادي والذين الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي
وايضا معنا محب الله شريف الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي وينضم الينا من واشنطن لا يكون
المساعد السابق ووزير الدفاع الامريكي و
كبير الباحثين في مركز التقدم الامريكي
سيد كورب هل لديك اي تفسير لاستمرار
اعتداءات الجنود الامريكيين على المدنيين
في افغانستان
من الصعب ان نسمع الصوت ولكن القضيه
المهمه هنا هي
معنا هذا فيما يتعلق بال استمرار بالوجود
الامريكي هناك وما هو نوع الاطار
الاستراتيجي ك اتفاقيه الذي يمكن ان نحصل
عليه مع افغانستان
بعد ان
تنتهي ولايه النيتو وتفويضه في الفين
واربعه عشر كما تعلمون الفرق الكبير كان
متعلقا
بتوصيل السجن في بدران وهذه هي حلت والان
الامر متعلق بالغارات الليليه التي تخوضها
الولايات المتحده لوحدها هذا بالاضافه الى
ما حدث بالنسبه ل اه حرق نسخ من القران وت
بول بعض جنود المرير على الجثه هذا ادى
الى
الخلاف بين البلدين وخاصه فيما يتعلق
بالغارات الليليه واستمرارها
ولكن هل قدمت الولايات المتحده لذلك
بشكل اساس هو
للولايات المتحده وحلفائها ان يستمر
بالتفاوض مع طالبان و
بتحويل
المسؤوليات الامنيه الافغانيه للشعب
الافغاني باسرع وقت ممكن
وبعد ذلك الحفاظ على قدراتها حتى من خارج
البلاد اذا تطلب الامر بالعوده اذا ما
اصبحت افغانستان ما وماذا القاعده المره
الثانيه والعمل ايضا مع القوى الاقليميه
كايران والصين وروسيا والهند وباكستان
لضمان ان افغانستان لا تهدد المنطقه سيد
فضل الهادي وزين هل ممكن التفاوض مع
طالبان وهل ممكن الان
الحديث عن استراتيجيه او عن معاهده بعد
الذي حصل بين كابول وواشنطن
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم بدايه اعزي الشعب
الافغاني وسط الضحايا
الابرياء
الترحم على الشهداء الابرياء الشيوخ
والاطفال والنساء الذين راحوا ضحيه
هذه المجزره البشعه التي ارتكبتها القوات
الامريكيه التي تدعي انها اكبر ال ال عبر
جيش نظامي في العافيه في العالم اعتقد ان
بعد هذه المجزره وما حدث المجازر السابقه
التي ارتكبتها القوات الامريكيه في
افغانستان
مثل مجال
عندها وهل ما وسندا والش
نوال كابيسا واخيرا منحرف القران الكريم
مساء المصحف الشريف في قاعده بغرام اعتقد
ان الوقت قد حان للرحيل القوات الامريكيه
من افغانستان وانه ان اي تفاوض مع
الامريكان مع القوات الامريكيه التي هي
ترتكب مثل هذه المجازر هي لا تاتي بنتيجه
وان الحل الامثل لانهاء هذه
الكوارث في افغانستان هو الرحيل للقوات
الامريكيه من افغانستان وترك الشعب
الافغاني حتى يقرر مصيره بنفسه
اليك سيدي محمد لتصريف هذا الحد اذا برحيل
القوات الاجنبيه عن افغانستان وتسليم من
القوات الافغانيه القوات الافغانيه جاهزه
الحكومه كرزاي مرضى عنها و باستطاعتها
تدبر امرها وحدها
لو نكون موضوعيين نستطيع ان نقول بان
القوات الافغانيه او الحكومه الافغانيه
الان في كابل غير قادره على في حقيقه
الامر على تدبير البلد و اخذ زمام اموره
كليا لاننا الان نواجه كاب الهيكل حكومي
ضعيف ومازال يعني
شكوى عن اكبر فساد اداري في داخله وكذلك
عدم تجهيز وعدم قدرات وعدم كفاءه عاليه
حتى تستطيع هذه القوات الامنيه او بصوره
عامه هذه الحكومه التي يراسها حامد كرزاي
في تدبير وتلزيم كل الامور التي سوف يتم
تسليمها من قبل القوات الدوليه او المجتمع
الدولي في حمايه حكومه كابول الى هذه
الحكومه الضعيفه التي بزعم وبعقيده لن
تكون قادره على تنظيم وتدبير كل زمام
الامور التي سوف تسلم اليها قريبا اذا
كانت بهذا البعض اذا ما الذي كان تفعله
القوات التدريبيه المتخصصه بالتدريب اذن
حتى الان نستطيع ان نقول بان المجتمع
الدولي لم يقم بواجبه كما كان من الواجب
وكما كان ضروريا وواجبا للشعب الافغاني
والقوات الافغانيه ان تتلقى تدريبا مهنيا
حقيقيا حتى تكون جاهزه عندما تنطلق وتخرج
هذه القوات من افغانستان تكون قادره لتسلم
جميع زمام الامور التي تتعلق حاليا
بالقوات الدوليه في ذلك الوقت الى القوات
الافغانيه لكن هذا كان شبه برنامج ان لا
تكون هذه القوات ومدربه وجاهزه تجهيزا
كليا حتى تستطيع ان تقوم بهذا الامر بدلا
من القوات الدوليه في افغانستان
سيد كون اذا تدريب مثل ضعيفا وعلى اي حال
كيف يمكن
جنود لديه ممارسات تعتبر ساءنا ومشينا
تحرق ال القران الكريم والتبول على الجثث
وايضا ارتكاب مجازر كالتي حدثت الاحد كيف
يمكن لهؤلاء ان يشكلوا مثلا القوات
الافغانيه هذا اولا ثانيا هنالك مخاوف من
عوده طالبان والقاعده
وايضا ثالثا هنالك مشكله في العلاقه بينكم
لواشنطن حاليا اذن التي كانت تفعل والقوات
الامريكيه هناك على مدى عشر سنوات اذا
كانت هذه هي النتيجه اخفاقات
كل من الاحداث الثلاث التي ذكرتها
فيه مشكله عميقه في جذوره اذا ما نظرنا
الى هذا الرقيب والذي لا نعرف اسمه والذي
ذهب الى القريه وقتل خمسه عشر شخصا بمن
فيهم اطفال صغر هذه هي ورديته الرابعه
ثلاثه الى العراق وهذه الاولى لافغانستان
في العشره اعوام الماضيه ولم يكن عنده وقت
ليستريح في وطنه ما بين هذه الورديات لكي
يستعيد عافيته ثانيه وعندما ننظر الى هذا
الامر نجد انه على الارجح قد عانى من
الصدمه المتعلقه بكونه بعيدا في منطقه
الصراع وعانى من اثار الصدمه
وتبعتها ولذلك هو محبط لان بعض الناس
الذين دربهم قد حولوا وتحولوا الى معادين
للامريكان الناس الذين يحرقون نسخه من
المصحف لم يكونوا على علم بالثقافه
الاسلاميه لانهم لم يدربوا على ذلك من
ضربوا على القتال ولكن ليس التعامل على
الثقافه التي هم في ذلك البلد التي يرونها
والثلاثه من قوات المارينز او مشاه
البحريه الذين قاموا بالتبول عندما يكون
هناك قتال يمكن للشخص ان يفقد احترامه
للاخرين وهذه الاحداث الثلاثه تظهروا
باننا قد تجاوزنا مرحله الترحيب بنا في
افغانستان والوقت حال للانسحاب واتوقع انه
عندما يكون هناك اجتماع للناتو فيه ما
يفيد شيكاغو بان كل القوى الدوليه سوف
تبدا بتخفيض قواتها حتى اسرع مما قد وضعت
جدول زمني لتحقيق ولكن
بنسبه للانسحاب ان الامريكيه اليوم كانت
في افغانستان تقول السوق في استطاعه
الانسحاب وحتى البريطانيون يقولون لن تغير
هذه الحادثه في خطه
وجودهم هناك
بشكل علني لن يقولوا اي شيء على هذا النحو
ولكن الرئيس قال انه يريد الانسحاب
على الاقل القوات التي يزيد عددها هذا
الصيف ان تحول المسؤوليات بشكل كامل الى
القوات الافغانيه بحلول الفين وثلاثه عشر
وهذا سيسمح للرئيس بان يسحب المزيد من
القوات ب الفين واثني عشر اعلى مما تمت
وقوه واعتقد انه بحلول الفين واربعه عشر
سيكون العدد ربما عشره الاف من القوات
الامريكيه باقين هناك اقول لك بالحرف ما
الذي قالت المستشاره الالمانيه عبرت عن
عدم ثقتها في انسحاب القوات الالمانيه مع
حلول عام الفين واربعه عشر كما كان مخططا
لها قال ذلك
البريطانيين ايضا نواجه وضعا تم قتل سته
بريطانيين هناك
من قبل اناس نظريا كانوا الى جانبنا اذن
هذا يعطيهم دافع للانسحاب واعتقد ان
اللقاء لن يتم في شيكاغو في شهر مايو
يوضع جدول زمني جديد لعمليه الانسحاب طيب
ابقى معنا ضيفنا وايضا ضيفينا من
سوف نكون مع بقيه هذه الحلقه بعد هذا
الفاصل ما هي التبعات المحتمله لم داخل
افغانستان وعلى مستوى علاقتها بالولايات
المتحده نناقش ذلك بعد فاصل قصير
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في حلقتنا التي تتناول
التداعيات الامنيه والسياسيه المحتمله
لمجزره قندهار سيد فضل الهادي وزين من
الضيف من كابول طالبان توعدت بالرد على
هذه المجزره الى اي حد يمكن ان يتفجر
العنف مجددا
اعتقد هذه المجزره ان الشعب الافغاني
كلها في موجه غضب ان موجه غضب الشعب
الافغاني
ستسعد وطبعا من حق الشعب الافغاني ان
يدافع عن نفسه حسب كل الاديان وكل
المواثيق ال ال الانسانيه وكل
القوانين
الوضعيه
فاعتقد ان موجه غضب عارمه
ستساعد في افغانستان هذا من جانب ومن جانب
اخر ان كراهيه الشعب الافغاني لمواجهه
الاحتلال ستزداد
وكذلك
افغانستان طبعا مثل هذه ال ال المجازر
التي ترتكب مثل هذه الاحداث التي تحدث في
افغانستان
تماهى لها تداعيات ولا ابعاد مختلفه منها
اه قد تكون هي خطوه
خطوه قد تكون هذه الخطه
لزعزعه الاستقرار في افغانستان وهو غير
مستقر اصلا يعني افغانستان وهي زياده حاله
عدم الاستقرار في
يعني اه قد تكون في
لان هذا مثل هذا الحادث واكيد انه ليس
كافيا وانما هو حادث متعمد لا يمكن ان يتم
تنفيذ مثل هذه المجزره البشعه في منطقه
بعد منتصف الليل قبيل الفجر الاب تخطيط
تخطيط من قبل
جهات معينه
الامريكيه قد تكون هي جهاد امريكيه قد
تكون الجهات داخل الاستخبارات الامريكيه
قد تكون اه جهات اخرى اخترقت
الجيش الامريكي قد تكون هي بنعمل المرتزقه
القتله الذين ارسلتهم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الى افغانستان
المختلفه في امريكا
المخدرات
وبالتالي كل ذلك ممكن يكون خلط الاوراق من
طرف وكذلك تكون هذه اضعاف حكومه حكومه
حامد كرزاي في افغانستان التي هي تعاني من
ضعف لانه اظهار هذه الحكومه كما هي حكومه
عاجزه ضعيفه وهي ضعيفه ف اه كذلك ان تكون
هذه الخطه من هذا الجانب يعني تحدثنا حتى
يتسلم من بدل كرزاي
يعني ليس قضيه يتسلم بعد كرزاي لكن يبدو
انه المواطن حاليا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حتى في الكونغرس في المجلس
الشيوخ الان يعني هناك محاولات لبحث ان ان
اجراء تحقيق او اه اجراء تحقيق حول انها
مدروسه الاستفاده من المعونات الامريكيه
في افغانستان فبالتالي انه اذا وضعنا هذا
في سياق التوتر العلاقات التي بين حكومه
حامد كرزاي وواشنطن قد يكون لها تداعيات
اخرى وبعض اخرى عموما مما تم مثل هذه
المجازر هي تبين الفشل الاخلاقي والفشل
الحضاري الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يعني
قد تكون لها تداعيات انا يعني على قضيه
وهويه تبين
تبين هشاشه ما تسمى مخطط توقيع
الاتفاقيه الاستراتيجيه بين افغانستان
وامريكا اظن انها توقيع هذه الاتفاقيه هي
نتائجها وتبعتها ظاهره من الان لانه في
وجود القوات الامريكيه لو تحدث مثل هذه
الم جاذب معنى ذلك ان افغانستان هي محدده
والشعب الافغاني مهدد لعده سنوات
لمثل هذه المجازر
لاعتبارات محض الله شريف
ترى في هذه النظريه نظريه مؤامره ان صح
التعبير
ام وجهات النظر ما في محلها
لا استطيع ان يعني انكر هذه الفكره بشكل
كلي ولكن لا استطيع ان انتمي اليه يعني
بكل صراحه وبكل حياده استطيع ان اقول بان
هذا الامر ربما كان خارج نطاق صلاحيات
الضبط
والتنظيم الاساسي لجميع تحركات وفعاليات
الجيش الامريكي في افغانستان
وحصل معظم وهذه
الافعال التي اتت بصوره كثيفه جدا
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه في الشعب
الافغاني وحتى في الامه الاسلاميه باكملها
استطيع ان اقول بعض هذه الفعاليات للجيش
الامريكي خارج نطاق السيطره الحقيقيه
عليها من قبل واشنطن لان معظم الذين جاؤوا
الى افغانستان في الجيش الامريكي وخاصه في
الدرجات السفلي هم من الذين التحقوا
بالجيش يعني لم يكونوا باخلاق حقيقيه كما
تليق بالجيش وخاصه جيش الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كما تبالي عليه ياتوا الى
افغانستان وارتكبوا بعض الامور اصلا لم
يكونوا في بالهم بان هذه سوف تجلب لهم
نتائج سوداء كما جلبت فعل بحرق المصحف
الشريف والسندات الدينيه ولذلك هذه
المجزره ومثلها اخرى في
الى
يدخل في دوامه عنف ويسقط ضحايا فيها هلا
في دعوه قد تلقى صدى ولكن مصطلح ان ان
يكون هناك حل سياسي وال اه اه تجري محاكمه
علنيه
للجامعه
المشكله الاساسيه في دعوه هؤلاء الزعماء
من القضاء ال انها يعني الاجابه لدعوه
هؤلاء الزعماء من القبائل في النهار مشكله
اساسيه التي تواجهها هذه الدعوه هي ان
الشعب الافغاني كيف سوف يجد محاكمه علنيه
لجندي امريكي دخل الى افغانستان وحتى هو
خرج من قاعده عسكريه وذهب وقتل ضحاياهم
عندما كانوا نائمين او في بيوتهم لم
يكونوا يفكرون في عمليات ارهابيه او
عسكريه ضد تلك القاعده التي هو كان يعيش
فيها حسب ما يزعم الناتو او المتحدثين
باسم هم في كابول لكن هذه الاستجابه كانت
من المتوقع ان تاتي طلبا لدعوه هؤلاء
الزعماء لو كانت هناك حقيقه محاكمه مثلما
حدث في مجزره يعني ما زالت قندهار في يعني
امس قبلها مجازر حدثت في افغانستان كانت
هناك تحقيقات لم تاتنا بنتيجه ولن تكون
هناك محاكمه علنيه حتى القضيه باضراب
هناك انتقادات كثيره للمحاكمات في احداث
سابقه
وايضا هناك الان انتقادات بانه المطلوب لم
يعد اذار لم يعد محاكمات حتى المطلوب
قياده واعيه لما يجري في افغانستان قياده
امريكيه واعيه والسؤال هو الان كيف سيؤثر
كل ما حدث على اي معاهده تحدد الشراكه
المستقبليه بين واشنطن وكابول بين القوات
الامريكيه
وكابول
ان هذا سيجعل من الشراكه امرا صعبا للغايه
وسوف
نقول
الشعب الافغاني يريد محاكمه هذا الجندي في
افغانستان ولكن هذا لن يحدث
ونظامنا القانوني طويل و
سيستغرق وقتا طويلا قبل ان تتم اي عمليه
تحقق العداله وهذا سيجعل من الصعب حتى
التعامل مع هذا الوضع وذلك لن وحسب نظامنا
القانوني الشخص بريء حتى تثبت ادانته
والعبء بالادانه هو يقع على الحكومه ولكن
لا اعتقد اننا سنقدم الناس في افغانستان
بان هذا يعتبر شخصا وحيدا او مجنون ولكنهم
يظنون بان هذا جزء من جهد امريكي لانه تم
ارسال
المروحيات لاحقه ولا شيء ظنون بالتالي بان
هذه عمليه من هذه العمليات شكرا جزيلا لك
لاري ك والمساعد السابق لوزير الدفاع
الامريكي ايضا اشكر فضل الهادي وزين
الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي الله الكاتب
والمحل كنت ما معنى
بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر ننتقل الى قراءه جديده في ما وراء
خبر
[موسيقى]
ام